the best part about today I would say is
how smoothly everything went with the
6th graders I just I I was stressed
about they actually had like pretty
constructive feedback so I I'm happy
about how that would the worst part
about today i feel like people feel lost
they kind of had a deer in the
headlights look on their faces sometimes
because we're really talking at a more
abstract conceptual level and they
haven't had a chance to really put stuff
into practice yet and i know that i'll
help or that'll change tonight and I
know that the workshops and stuff will
help tomorrow and the rest of this week
but at some point I just felt like i was
saying words that weren't super useful
to them I couldn't stop i should have
just shut up but i did reconfiguring our
furniture arrangement to this u-shape
definitely made the class feel more
intimate and i think that maybe that
contributed to them talking a lot more
compared to yesterday i mean there are a
lot of confounding variables with that
but they did seem to talk a lot more I
could do anything different today maybe
leaving more time for scripting I really
was going to rely on tomorrow to be the
big scripting day and I realize now that
that probably wasn't the greatest idea
because people don't know how to script
and of course they don't because who
does if you haven't ever done it before
I'm excited about tomorrow because it's
a more calm day to my relaxed it's more
formal